the rabbit growth of remote work has
given people more freedom to pick the
places they like to live and earn a
living and lately more Americans have
been choosing Mexico including Mexico
City CBS News correspondent Enrique
Acevedo reports on how the sprawling
Capital with its culture great food and
affordable real estate has become a work
from home paradise and shows us how the
new arrivals are being welcomed
[Music]
besides sounds and flavors of Mexico
City are tempting for people looking to
leave the Mexican dream like John Hyatt
you know the cafes the restaurants
everything you know just seeing the food
on the plates and people sipping coffee
it's a very pleasurable experience to
just be walking up and down the street
boarding North Carolina Hyatt helps U.S
and Canadian firms that are currently
Manufacturing in China relocate to
Mexico
[Music]
and it's not just companies looking to
come here Mexico is now a tough
destination for young professionals who
work remote technology has absolutely
made Mexico City and living down here
much easier you know we talk about
things like ride share apps you know we
have all of that the influx of American
expats is transforming some of Mexico
City's most traditional neighborhoods
but some say the change was already
underway so what I'm hearing is that the
pandemic didn't really start that it's
just like with everything else
accelerated yeah accelerated that's
that's the perfect it just threw some
gas on the Flames it was it was going to
happen anyway rents have soared in
colonial Roma a quiet walkable
neighborhood in a city tortured with
bumper-to-bumper traffic here Old World
charm is fading in its place
award-winning restaurants and cheap
coffee shops where customers speak
English more than Spanish our cultures
are kind of merging in many ways Mexico
is becoming more Americanized and the
United States Americans are taking a lot
more interest in Mexican culture and
Cuisine most locals welcome the new
arrivals and their dollars with
characteristic Mexican warmth
but tensions are growing around what
some are calling gentrification I think
there's a positive and negative to all
of this that you're that you're
mentioning and yes it's not just Mexico
right that's being gentrified as you say
there's many cities
I think that some of the positives I
think that they drive economy I think
people will get paid higher salaries
Alexandra demu is the founder of Welcome
Home Mexico a relocation and real estate
service she helps expats with everything
from these negotiations
to School interviews for their children
she says business has been booming since
the onset of the covid-19 pandemic with
no signs of slowing down now we have
younger Americans that can work remotely
looking for a better quality of life and
they're coming now to Mexico City and
when you say a better quality of life
what is it about Mexico City that
Americans like so much they love the
climate they love the people the culture
the food the beauty yes of course safety
can be an issue and when I say quality
of life I mean of course we can't avoid
the fact that your dollar goes a long
way in Mexico no things are still
relatively reasonable in Mexico
according to State Department data there
are over 1.6 million U.S citizens living
in Mexico but that number only includes
people who have applied for legal
residency which most remote workers
don't do Mexico City's tourism agency
says that just in the first half of this
year over 1.9 million foreigners arrived
at the cities International Airport
spending almost two billion dollars on
hotel stays in the capital Mexico has
always been an important destination for
U.S Travelers as I'm sure you know and I
have to say our Mexican hosts are
incredible Catherine Powell is the
global head of Hosting for Airbnb where
she oversees the host insights and
research team she says more people are
visiting Mexico and staying for longer
periods of time so we've seen an
incredible growth in long-term stays in
particular so these are stays over 28
days or more and you mentioned Mexico I
mean Mexico now one in five of that
night's booked are for long-term stays
in 1978 the Mexican poet Octavio pass
said in general Americans have not
looked for Mexico in Mexico
they have looked for their obsessions
enthusiasms phobias hopes and interests
nearly half a century later many wonder
if this might still hold true for
Mexico's newcomers
for CBS Saturday morning Enrique Acevedo
Mexico City
I did not realize that 1.6 million U.S
citizens lived in Mexico and they say
that's an undercount right because
that's the ones who registered to be
living there not going on tours and it's
not just happening in Mexico I mean I
was in Europe it's happening in Italy
it's happening in Greece it's happening
in Portugal they say more Americans are
buying property now than other Europeans
in that Nation well and you even look
especially obviously the pandemic impact
of people saying I can work remotely
this now is I would rather be here than
living over here or changing your costs
cost of living yeah next week's show
live from Mexico City
I'm in it's not going to happen no I
mean we'd like it to right